and here he is taking the field for the
first time in a big league game only 21
years old masa in the dominican republic
rowan si contreras pirate prospects this
is one of the better ones feel ortega
will be the first batter contreras faces
oh and that is a fair ball
96 miles an hour on the inside edge of
the plate and ortega whacks it in the
right wilson cone trimmers will face
rouenzy contreras up the middle and
that'll get through past the diving
into center field and a couple of balls
hard hit the exit below on that just to
shade under a hundred so first and
second one out for ian half and his
first major league strikeout will also
be thrown out of play and that's a big
one to get ian half that was the that
was the fastball that he was trying to
throw to wilson contreras with two
strikes that just didn't quite get to
the top of the zone and you see what you
see with 97 with ryde at the the top of
the zone with two strikes looks like um
out of rowanza contreras
chop to short and that's a six four put
out so
his first major league inning is in the
books ronci contreras now the pirates
come to bat they all go up against kyle
hendricks yeah the starting pitcher for
the cubs kyle looking to get out of the
first inning that has plagued them all
year unscathed if he can here
as he paints the corner and freezes
and a good start to strikeout looking
there's brian reynolds with two down oh
now this ball spanked to center field
and that ball is going to get past
ortega reynolds will have at least three
and he is going to be at third with a
trip trip triple and picks up where he
left off last night as he tries to march
toward 300. ortega just can't get there
in time reynolds is on third moran the
batter patrick's ready and fires
and he got him kyle hendricks pitches
around the triple and the pirates leave
a man second inning on its way rowanse
contreras back out for the pirates
there's a swing and a miss on a slider
that moved out of the zone so the first
time he saw it he didn't swing at it but
with two strikes
a little more lateral movement and not
really straight down so two outs yeah
now i got a chance if you take care of
alcatra you got the pitcher leading off
next setting and got him looking how
about that ronci contreras
strikes out bodhi and alcantara couple
of scoreless innings
ben gamel leading off the pirates second
inning
oh nice play in the backhand
good job by alcantara
diving stabbed
and that one was ticketed for center
field alcantara with a great diving stop
but even better what a cannon he's got
of an arm to come up there and make that
not even a close play at first base 21
year old righty roncey contreras so far
two scoreless he's faced eight batters
he has struck out three
it takes care of
kyle hendricks so he has struck out four
and that makes three in a row scoreless
game third inning the batter frank
schwendell puts a charge into this one
out towards center reynolds near the
wall and that one up against the wall
and schwendell has himself a double
and that one just missed getting out to
wilson contreras from rowan c contreras
ground ball to third little stumble
there and the throw kind of off balance
and blind by hoy park gets the out of
wilson contreras only park recovers
throws a strike to moran ronci contreras
major league debut three scoreless
runners at first and second nobody out
caught safe frank couldn't quite get it
frank saying up didn't get it if he
slides straight back in the bag frank
schwendel's able to slap the tag on him
for a double play instead he contorts
his body and is able to get in there no
score first and second
on the ground to third duffy
they're able to turn the young ending
double play and this one stays scoreless
one way and back to the top of the order
and raphael ortega
up the middle base hit second knock of
the night for raphael ortega one out a
man aboard and come see if they could
get something together with one out the
tank at the plate frank schwendell
and schwendell
another multi-hit game
a single to center or take it a third
and they're at the corners
with one out slider kind of middle of
the plate stays back on it wilson
contreras in the box he's one for two on
the night
center field well struck reynolds back
near the wall
and he makes the catch ortega scores
schwindel tags and makes second and the
cubs have a one nothing lead wilson
contreras comes through for the last
half of the fifth inning in pittsburgh
michael perez leading things off
right there another strikeout kyle
has four of them here tonight
and he has struck him out twice swung
two times now
on the ground alcantara steadies
[Applause]
is retired and hendricks continues to do
good work opportunity with the leadoff
hitter aboard to start the inning
reynolds has tripled and walked and he
hits this in the air deep to center
field sending ortega back toward the
track and off the fence tsutsugo look
back over his shoulder he will head to
the plate he will score brian reynolds
on fire brings home sutsugo to tie the
game two triples on the night for brian
reynolds and this ball is just
absolutely tattooed a few feet from
getting over that fence morgan came in
last night to get the lefties out and he
couldn't do it and here tonight he can't
do it either he just loaded the bases
and now he's got to face a righty in
newman
the pitch swinging a high fly ball
toward the notch
ortega back on this one shy of the track
he'll make the catch reynolds tags all
three runners will tag all three runners
will get up and the pirates take the
lead on the sac fly by kevin newman two
to one pirates
one out here's trace thompson to hit for
adam morgan
that's drilled out towards left field
towards the gap and it gets past gamble
and thompson into second so the tying
run
is in the scoring position as that was
hard hit and that's outside ball four
shreve walks schwendell schwendell takes
off from first and there'll be no throw
thompson the runner at third
schwendell at second contreras drove in
the cubs run with a fifth inning sac fly
[Applause]
that's gonna score two
contreras into second
and the cubs have the lead it's 3-2
wilson contreras a two-run double i mean
an absolute bullet
to right center field how about this
trent chambroni is going to make his
major league debut right here
and a base hit in the left field
welcome to the show that is awesome
they'll grab the baseball and congrats
to trent big smiles
walks them and they're loaded now for
frank schwendel
lift it toward right this should do it
tsutsugo makes the catch keeps it a
one-run deficit
contreras the big hit tonight that
two-run double
to center field deep reynolds back
and he makes the catch
brian reynolds how good is he is there
anything that he cannot do that is not
an easy play for for all of you out
there this is not an easy play that he
makes
looks so simple
he is so good one away ninth inning
batter is ian ham
rifles that one down the line that's a
fair ball sesugo picks it up fires it in
and for ian half his first hit of the
night and a walk after the intentional
walk that loads the bases pushing up the
runners two and two on sergio alcantara
with the bases loaded swinging a mess he
struck him out bases are left loaded for
the cubs pirates are down to their last
chance the batter is cole tucker
[Applause]
martini near the wall and he makes the
catch and that'll do it and hoyer able
to close it out for the save and the
cubs hang on and win it 3-2 the final